en el siguiente conjunto de vídeos vamos
a hablar de algo llamado sistema de
comentario qué significa eso podemos
entender que es el sistema
cardiovascular o el sistema respiratorio
o el sistema urinario pero a qué se
refieren con te comentario que comprende
el sistema de comentario en realidad
vamos a hablar de dos cosas el sistema
de comentario comprende tanto la piel
como sus anexos también llamados maneras
ahora aquí nos suena anexo un anexo
puede ser algo que cuelgan o que es
parte de algo por ejemplo tu brazo es
parte de tu torso los anexos del sistema
de comentario incluyen cosas como las
uñas el pelo en la cabeza o en los
brazos o en cualquier otro lugar y
también cosas como las glándulas
sudoríparas
las glándulas en general caen en esta
clasificación hablaremos con mayor
detalle de estos anexos más adelante
primero quiero que nos enfoquemos en la
piel llegamos una descripción general
porque la piel es el órgano más grande
de nuestro cuerpo pesa casi 10
kilogramos es mucho más pesado que el
hígado o los pulmones y sin embargo
muchos de nosotros podemos pasar un día
entero sin pensar en las funciones de la
piel así que cuáles son estas funciones
de la piel si dijéramos que éste es tu
brazo y tienes un pulgar arriba este es
tu puño y tu antebrazo que es lo que la
piel de tu brazo te permite hacer
fácilmente nos podemos dar cuenta de que
cuando el bebé y caen gotas sobre
nuestra cabeza la piel nos permite ser
impermeables al agua la piel es
impermeable al agua y a otras cosas que
intentan penetrar sus capas e ir a
nuestros órganos o nuestra sangre
es impermeable no puede cruzarse y esto
es cierto para el agua y otras moléculas
como este virus que estamos dibujando
justo aquí dibujemos su cápside y sus
pequeñas patitas quiere entrar e
infectar las células de tu cuerpo pero
afortunadamente tu piel no le permite el
paso ya que es impermeable
pero no es solo una barrera estructural
también tiene una función inmunológica
la piel puede secretar anticuerpos o
enzimas como lisos y más que se hacen
cargo de eliminar estos virus o
bacterias con intenciones de enfermarte
los anticuerpos pueden cubrir a este
malvado de aquí y las lisos y más le
ayudan rompiendo la pared celular para
proteger tu piel por lo tanto tu piel
también funciona como parte del sistema
inmunitario la inmunidad también está en
juego no sólo por estos anticuerpos o
estas dichos y más ya que tal vez puedes
imaginar un escenario donde la bacteria
penetra algunas capas de tu piel y
piensa que tiene una oportunidad de
establecerse o de producir una infección
o un absceso en algún lugar y sin
embargo tú tienes células dentro de las
capas externas de tu piel como las
células de langerhans
que se comen estas bacterias y evitan
que se establezcan o que no se enfermen
además de la inmunidad la piel nos ayuda
a percibir cosas del medio ambiente si
tenemos está el filler podemos pinchar
los y realmente nos dolerán la piel le
dirá el cerebro oye tal vez no debemos
poner nuestra mano tan cerca de este
objeto puntiagudo es decir tu piel
también tiene la responsabilidad de
percibir el ambiente conduce las
sensaciones puede darse cuenta cuando
hay un estímulo que es doloroso
entonces percibe el dolor también
percibe distintas temperaturas cuando
algo es frío o caliente y también puede
diferenciar distintos tipos de contacto
por ejemplo puede discriminar entre
texturas también puede diferenciar si
algo solo te está rozando la mano o si
te está presionando fuertemente y
finalmente cuando hace mucho calor en el
exterior ya mencionamos que tiene la
capacidad de
y la temperatura entonces la piel tiene
la habilidad de responder con un proceso
que se llama sudoración y eso ya lo
sabemos sudamos porque nuestra piel y
sus glándulas forman parte de un proceso
general llamado termorregulación porque
nuestro sudor nos permite refrescarnos
por un proceso cuyo nombre es
enfriamiento por evaporación
pero también hay procesos que involucran
tus vasos sanguíneos para que hay un
vaso sanguíneo en tu brazo que nos ayuda
a conducir al calor hacia afuera de
nuestro cuerpo vamos a deshacernos de
este calor porque sabemos que también en
el exterior hay calor la piel es mucho
más que sólo una barrera hay muchas
cosas que la piel hace por nosotros y en
los siguientes vídeos entraremos en los
detalles de cómo se logran todas estas
funciones